one of the main arguments i make here on
the bioneer is that physical training
and cognitive training should go hand in
hand
few characters in fiction embody this
philosophy like
deathstroke the terminator while the
explanations have been pseudo-scientific
at times
slade is generally said to be able to
think nine times faster than a normal
human
this is what allows him to go toe-to-toe
with the likes of batman and nightwing
he is a master tactician he picks up new
martial arts with ease
and he has heightened speed and decision
making in combat
and this is where things get really
interesting because if you could
increase your working memory
a core component of iq then it actually
could help you to become a better mover
and maybe even a combat prodigy this is
something that can be achieved to a more
subtle degree
with the right kind of training in this
video i will argue that anyone can
benefit from a cognitive skills training
day
in their routine here's what that should
look like inspired by the calculating
mercenary
of course if you want to see how this
might fit into a broader training
program
you could also check out my ebook and
training routine super functional
training
there's a link down below and it's
currently on discount or keep listening
and i'll tell you how this all works and
how you can design your own skills day
so working memory is your capacity to
store and manipulate information
in the short term when performing maths
for example
you use your working memory to carry
numbers or keep the question in mind
while working
this is what much of the research
focused on for years but working memory
is also what we use to store information
about the world around us
when playing sports for example we use
working memory to remember where the
other players are on the pitch
something similar occurs when you're
moving normally through space because
you can only focus on a narrow amount of
information at any given time
you therefore need to build up a picture
of the world around you that is
constantly updated
see my recent video and post on training
reflexes focus and decision making like
john wick
this way working memory can improve your
vision for driving in sports as well as
your ability to react
dynamically to changing scenes all of
this is crucial in combat
if deathstroke could hypothetically
attempt to more information at once
he might be able to maintain a more
complete picture of his current
situation
and react to small changes more rapidly
this of course would make him a far more
lethal combatant and could explain his
tactical mind
but what's more is that working memory
also helps you to move your body
and learn new skills that's motor
learning
if you've ever been taught how to punch
or how to swing a golf club you'll
likely remember being given lots of
information about how to move
when punching you need to rotate the
hips and the shoulders you need to keep
loose until the last minute
depending on the style of martial arts
you must also rotate the fist as it
travels
this is a lot to remember and that's
just the tip of the iceberg keeping all
of this in mind during the early stages
of motor learning
requires working memory and attention
this is what p fitz and m posner
described as the cognitive phase of
learning motor skills
the point at which you still need to
consciously control your movements
so if slade has a greater working memory
he can increase the awareness
of his own body and thereby move each
limb and muscle as instructed
this could help him to rapidly learn new
martial arts and to deliver more power
with each strike
and this is not hypothetical in one
study it was found that children with
greater working memories
responded better to instructions when
learning basketball shooting
learning faster and to greater effect
several more studies have shown similar
results
in one it was found that the performance
of karate pupils in sparring
could be significantly improved with an
intervention involving working memory
training
that's right specifically training
working memory with a battery of
computer tests
could improve fighting ability the study
authors hypothesized that the gains in
performance were due to improved skill
acquisition during training
between tests however they also
explained that it could be due to
improved awareness
and decision making during contests even
when moving in an unstructured way
a better working memory would
theoretically allow you to maintain a
more complete image of your own body
in a similar study it was shown that
improving working memory using a
computer game called
musical catch could reduce falls in
participants aged 60 to 80.
by focusing in on the role of working
memory and movement i hope i've
demonstrated the clear role for
cognitive training
for any serious athlete or anyone
looking to improve their general
performance
but how do we incorporate this kind of
training to improve movement and motor
skill acquisition
we need more multi-sensory pro receptive
training for working memory
the good news is that there are
countless options when it comes to
complex and proprioceptively demanding
movement
that can reliably benefit executive
function and working memory
one example is balance training or
unstable surface training
combined with resistance training the
effectiveness of such training methods
for building dynamic athleticism
is the subject of much debate but the
cognitive benefits have been
demonstrated repeatedly
in one study movements such as squats on
a bosu ball were shown to improve
working memory
processing speed response inhibition and
set shifting
in healthy older adults but these
benefits likely have more to do with the
balance and coordination
than with the weights themselves adults
that undertake acute proprioceptively
demanding training
enjoy an improved working memory
according to one study
examples include crawling along beams
climbing trees and running barefoot
and the clue comes from the phrase
proprioceptively demanding
by requiring the individual to focus on
input and control across the body
these exercises require sharp focus and
the juggling of information
just like manipulating numbers in our
mind's eye
you don't necessarily need to buy a
balance board to enjoy these benefits
while i couldn't find any specific
studies confirming the theory
it follows that hand balancing would
offer similar advantages
the same should certainly be true for
gymnastics rings the benefits of
slacklining appear to be even more
pronounced
as this is an extremely challenging form
of balance training
in one study it was found that
slacklining could improve jump
performance and postural control
moreover brain scans revealed enhanced
efficiency
in the striatal network of the brain a
region responsible for motor learning
self-initiated movements and the
execution of complex action sequences
quadrupedal movements especially
combined with balancing are also
effective for improving joint
repositioning
and markers of cognition juggling is a
slightly different example
that has also been shown to boost
working memory and many other cognitive
skills
juggling has this effect as you must not
only consider the movement of your own
hands
but also the movement of the balls in
the air but this also explains why 3d
object tracking tools are so effective
for developing forms of working memory
i've spoken before about how much i've
personally benefited from the oculus
quest app called react performance
trainer
in fact this experience was partly what
inspired this post
moreover we need to focus on focus
itself focus
is most likely the gatekeeper of working
memory our working memory is born from
our ability to sustain activation in
certain neural networks
so that lasting impressions remain in
fact the controlled attention model of
working memory
suggests that they're effectively one
and the same and studies demonstrate
this clearly
when we are mindful of our movement we
move faster and more accurately
when we're distracted our movements
become sloppy this is where exercises
like dual end back can be beneficial
and have some transfer specifically
directive forms of meditation that
involve focused attention
in one cool study it was shown that
meditation could reduce a phenomenon
known as attentional blink this
describes the lull between attentional
shifts
the psychological refractory period in
other words
it can directly affect your ability to
switch between tasks and therefore
improve the ooda loop this would have
huge tactical advantages in combat
that study used a form of meditation
called integrative mind-body meditation
anecdotal reports describe how
meditating regularly can increase
general awareness colors look brighter
and even the taste and smell of a glass
of whiskey is felt more vividly
this makes sense in the context of
everything we've discussed you're now
able to take in more information from
the world around you
and hang on to it as you examine and
disseminate it
many people struggle with directive
meditation because they lack immediate
feedback
the mind wanders and they may not even
realize it my solution is to replace
traditional forms of meditation
with focused mental arithmetic for
instance i'll close my eyes for 10
minutes and increase
two to three numbers by different steps
this is surprisingly hard to do as you
catch your mind wandering
i call this computational meditation and
while there are no studies about this
seeing as i just made it up there is
evidence that focusing on mental
arithmetic
can provide similar benefits to
meditation such as heightened emotional
control
another cool option is any form of
moving meditation such as tai chi
tai chi is a controlled meditative
movement that places the focus acutely
on proprioception
unsurprisingly tai chi has been shown to
have direct benefits for working memory
now you may be wondering why you can't
just focus on a computer game or a good
film
the answer may have to do with stimulus
intensity it is much easier for us to
focus on something that's loud and
explosive
this pulls our attention in and may use
the ventral attentional network
conscious sustained attention on
something non-stimulating is effectively
a different skill
in one study it was found that just 80
minutes of meditation in four 20-minute
stints
was enough to significantly improve
participants working memory verbal
fluency and visuospatial processing
the same effect was not found for the
control group but spent the same time
listening to the lord of the rings
on audiobook
so my recommendation for deathstroke
training then is to incorporate a day of
more cognitively demanding
proprioceptively complex focused
training
that can include unstable surface
training hand balancing tai chi
yoga slack lining juggling martial arts
object tracking
dual n-back training and directive
meditation
this should be combined with a training
program designed to help us act on those
rapid decisions that means fast
explosive training combined with high
work capacity for endurance
you might be rolling your eyes now and
thinking that this all sounds a bit
silly
a death straight workout that concludes
you should take up toss juggling
on the contrary i think it's awesome
meditation concentration drills and
holding crisp handstands
sounds exactly like the sort of thing
that an experienced mercenary
at the top of their game should be doing
this is refined
intelligent training why do you need to
train your proprioception and awareness
i'd argue that this is every bit as
useful as training max strength
for the average joe it can prevent falls
and accidents
juggling for example develops the brain
in regions relating to peripheral vision
imagine what that could do for your
driving your sports or anything else
we should think of this as a crucial
pillar of general preparedness
an athlete with greater proprioception
and an increased ability to consider all
this information at once
will acquire new skills more quickly and
all of us can benefit from gaining
greater control and awareness of our own
movement
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did please
consider leaving a like and sharing it
around
that helps me out immensely comment down
below and let me know what you think
about this kind of training
do you train your awareness and complex
movement like i said if you want to see
a full training program that
incorporates this kind of thing
be sure to check out my ebook and
training routine super functional
training the link is in the description
down below
and there's a discount on at the moment
while we're all dealing with the
pandemic
let me know what topics you'd like me to
cover in future videos and i'll do my
best to get to them
either way thanks a ton for watching
this one and i'll catch you next time
bye for now